[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
if you hear a sound in your neighborhood
who
[Music]
who you gonna come
[Music]
oh
[Music]
who you
[Music]
now you're getting raped in your own
damn bed
they're gonna kill them they're gonna
kill that dude
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com shirts shorts and hoodies
oh my that's how you support the fight
with demonetization and all
make yourself look cool and help all the
right people.com
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
this mug is half empty so i didn't get
enough velocity
i was thinking about grabbing my pipe
and using the pipe but then it would
taste like old pipe tobacco
i wouldn't do that in a matter of
speaking delicious uh hey we have a lot
to we have so much to get today but look
dave landau is back yes ahoy everyone
how are you sir i'm
i'm good i'm living good he's coming in
a little bit hot a little bit hot dave
leno on that microphone we have uh
coming in hot
matching my looks how are you yeah you
know come on you gotta one of these days
you gotta be like just
fantastic i am grateful for another day
above ground in what used to be the
greatest country in the world
i i said on the world i mean in the
world
yeah very racist foundations sir and you
have to it has racist foundations
including the cops including the family
yeah everything
yeah all of it including the powdered
wigs uh including the tea
yes uh what else schools all of yeah all
of it we're gonna
we're gonna talk about all of that today
uh speaking of which quarterback garrett
is here hey
so he has a quarter pass picking up with
uh and dave
before so the theme today let me be
really we have a few things to get into
but i want you to think of the
overarching theme most people are
cowards and we're going to get into
critical race theory in schools
we're going to get into uh community
policing which means don't call the
police now now they
there's a movement not only to defund
the police but to try and shame people
in
areas where there is a significant
amount of crime shame them out of
calling the police
that sounds safe uh also mob was also
community police if i recall i think so
that's how they made their money
protection
they were respected they were respecting
i keep hearing you you guys are coming
in a little bit hotter
it's good no it's okay so dave you uh
you uh you have a date coming up this
weekend
i do uh virginia beach virginia the
funny bone oh
yes very nice yeah tickle it
and you're a little tired because you
were uh you were traveling back here i
was traveling back here from vegas we uh
we were we uh
could not come in because of the weather
right so they were in austin
we were we're on a runway in austin and
i got to tell you when somebody
is on a spirit flight that's your first
mistake
dave well first everybody's trying to
decide how much you know
what they can get out of it you know
yelling like we all need 300 points
and then this woman stands up and she's
like oh lord and like fakes fainting
and larry because she's sitting on the
tarmac yeah like she was older but it
just
was fake she thought she was i think it
was pretty it's pretend yeah because
everybody's like looking back at her
and the best part was when the flight
attendant goes is there a doctor on the
plane and it's spirit air so there's
nothing
at least i was before my script had got
a looser
is there a doc oh god i'm on spirit
david dow when you need him yeah so they
bring emts on the plane and then they
finally take her off the plane even
though
she didn't want to get off the plane
anymore because she was leaking
yeah legally she had to she may have
been arrested
i felt bad she was a little older but it
was just like trying to game the system
and got arrested
to get to your next flight and it's like
they're not everybody was so mad and
it's like do you want him to fly into
dallas like we'll just die
right and then we had to go from dallas
to here
so it was just like unreal wow well i'm
glad you got here mostly safely
uh okay there's a lot to get into but uh
first
you guys may have missed this we didn't
talk about it yesterday we should have
this happened over the weekend
oh yeah time for this week in biden wait
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
ma'am i guess i'm not so this next clip
just so you know it it makes about as
much sense as tenet and
we talked about this yesterday did you
watch that film yeah i
i attempted it it's terrible yeah i shut
it off everything's horrible yeah
i hate him it's it's the kind of film
that stupid people think is a really
intelligent film yes it's uh james bond
but not at all right you said you hate
him do you don't not you don't like
christopher nolan
yeah oh okay but it's just like what
after i saw inception i was just like go
to hell
inception was good no it was that was
like the last one
there's always a game it's like hey
what's this one gonna be i don't know
will the
central uh foreshadowing plot element be
uh time oh
who'd have thought one big giant
adventure
okay so this is by just so you know it
makes about as much sense as tenant i'm
pretty tired
dave is pretty tired even then this
still doesn't make sense it's biden
talking about
really a subject where he has a certain
level of expertise amtrak
if you think about it when we were
when i was vice president with barack he
allowed me to put together
a budget for amtrak and it had money for
high-speed rail
at 200 miles an hour from
from uh uh assuming from charlotte he's
doing math now one
another line going from in florida
down to tampa another line if we had
moved
gov we had that tunnel fixed in new york
now the money was there to get it done
what the what are we doing well
former vice president joe biden the
little engine that couldn't i like it i
don't care about the
express i just it makes look i feel why
is his family not looking out for yeah i
know
i don't know his i just like that his
hat's busted sideways like he's a [ __ ]
yeah he looks like he's about to dj yeah
and then forget where he's at yeah just
put on the mouse ears
teach me you know how to dougie brain
dead shuffle
you know the thing with amtrak all right
this has been this weekend biden
there's a whole problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
he's right you ain't black i'm not dang
it
again
if marilyn monroe were to sing him happy
birthday he'd poop his pants and wonder
where he was for a second what did
someone turn on the microwave
no it's the starlet of the decade
singing you happy birthday
ah i need to change my depends except
now it would be lizzo
yeah nobody would want to be there it'd
be
uh megan my ass you'd be a bottom feeder
catfish carp is that your [ __ ]
what what's the crustacean i don't eat
shellfish
i'm not a jew come on get this adult out
of here i need a child uh and this is
something i want to talk about a little
bit too again when do you think
republicans are largely useless right
now uh i hate to be like these booth
parties man
but they really are mostly spineless
with a few exceptions people like
desantis people like ted cruz
uh in a lot of ways um you know george
carlin has a famous quote where he said
take the dumbest person you know you
know take the an average person and then
understand that if you look at the bell
curve half of the population is dumber
than that
and that's a funny quote however i think
more important than just intelligence
is backbone is moral fortitude and we
have you have a bell curve most
people are spineless think of the
average person you know
think of whether they would intervene
whether they would help someone in need
whether they would stand up for what
matters whether they would speak out
when they know that they would face some
kind of public backlash and understand
that at least half of the population are
more cowardly than that and i want to
really quickly before we go on with this
this is important too because right now
you hear
we're just talking about megan the
stallion all these people saying i'm
fearless it's a lot no one is fearless
and the problem with that is we assume
that people who are brave don't have
fear
as opposed to teaching young people how
to exercise courage which is
doing the right thing in the face of
fear like at a pta meeting
like with a local police department like
being a juror
at the shaving trial like critical race
theory
so we'll go through quite a few examples
and i i i want to hear from you you can
comment below
when you think that this coward has
permeated this country because
like it or not we have a second
amendment because this country was
it was founded on courage look i come
from canada we still have the queen in
our money we bent over and kissed the
ring
it's not the same thing okay oh before
that let's before we get to all that
let's talk uh it's time to talk about
don lemon oh
[Music]
so last night on cnn don lemon argued
with
chris cuomo yeah that's a split screen
that gives children nightmares
oh yes chris cuomo and don lemon
uh i don't know which is worse that or
then the split screen that follows with
anderson cooper and wolf blitzer wolf
oh that is terrible yes or then on the
weekend you can get sanjay gupta or dr
fariza and
brian stelter and jake just keeps going
down yeah it's weird because
anderson cooper and wolf blitzer does
look like
he transformed into him right yeah a
little bit like that's the gay werewolf
right
like celebrity jeopardy just sucked his
soul out
along with all his points lowest score
ever on celebrity jeopardy well blitz
was like negative 6 000.
so don limon money wolf you went into
celebrity jeopardy and you cost the
charity money
you get nothing there's some kid with
pro jiri on his last breath going
damn you wolf right after that rebecca's
like i don't know what i just saw but my
side hurts but i'll beat it
has a happy ending so don limon and uh
chris cuomo uh were arguing about the
solution to what they call the
delusional
and by the way when i let me set this up
when they say delusional right they mean
people who believe you know for example
that your rights are being encroached
upon their identity politics
sowing division in this country or that
you know um we may need to reform
our uh election our not our electoral
process you are the guys who
mean in the left they want to do away
with the electoral college uh and they
want to make dc estate
we simply want to have you know
identification tomato tomato i know you
think
voter id is radical i think changing you
know
dc to a state and uh i think changing
the elect
abolishing the electoral college a
little more but that's just me
the abc's of me i'm that's me mr vegas
so uh here we go to them arguing about
the final
solution there is a wager being made
on the right that they can get
enough white people to believe
that they are targeted that there's been
a perverse culture shift
and that they are being replaced true
no but it's not about facts it's about
fear you know that people already know
that and the people in the republican
party
know that that's why 90 percent of them
that's why they haven't interrupted
biden didn't win
that party accepts
that doesn't the big lie right that
doesn't make it right and that doesn't
mean of course it doesn't make it right
what i'm saying is if it were as simple
as no value being added to your
situation we got to go because we're not
going to agree i agree
because i know where you're coming from
and i love you don yeah i love you too
you agree on the problem what's the
solution we got to figure it out
i got a big i got a solution but whoa
hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa solution let's be careful
hey
that's a weird edit day at cnn jeez
don't use the word i have a solution in
dealing with your political opposition
it typically doesn't help yeah it's
probably a good look yeah uh speaking of
which and we don't need to do the next
stinger here but uh
cowardice while we're talking about
systems i was about to say this is all
this is all
based on rick santorum saying that
native americans didn't necessarily
affect
what our founding documents represented
as a country of course that's what this
all was built up on yeah like i can't
believe he didn't just come on and
apologize and say he was completely
wrong
don lemon said he had a blm kind of
moment for native americans
when he saw that you mean you started
huffing windex pretty much
well he looks like he just huff nitrous
he's always just like his eyes are
rolling around
yeah yeah and he's about to cry mostly
that's all he does though he's having
rolls
rolls his gay club drug oh of course he
is
what's the what's the one that you crack
it gives you immediate brain damage it's
like smelling salts only for gay clubs
really well like what i'm talking about
no joe rogan talked about when i was
when i was oh dmt
no it's not gmt i know i mentioned joe
rogan right away we go to b and dmc yeah
nitrous i don't know if it's nitrous
there's something possible
like they did a study and they found
that it immediately causes brain damage
you mean the old liberace
yes he enjoyed one with his
friend yeah exactly why aren't you
married i don't know
i don't know i just haven't find the
right cow
looking it's really is that part of yeah
hopefully settling down is in the cards
or settling into a man oh why am i
saying this
oh me my friends all have a bad cough
why are you losing weight so quickly and
have bags under your eyes liberace
oh it must be the chemical from my dry
cleaning let you get into my system
how'd it happen oh i think it's aids
whoops
that was it speaking of cowardice that
must be it
speaking of and by the way you know what
this is how far we've come liberace
i guarantee would be a blast to hang out
with oh guaranteed
gay folks from the 90s even the early
arts they were so much more fun than the
elliot pages
richard simmons yeah richard simmons he
sounds great i want to party with that
guy
a copper blast yes don't drink anything
from him though
housekeeper uh okay let me move on to
this here this this is
look first let me be really clear i know
that there are a lot of catholics out
there and i am not catholic and i have
talked about how i disagree with some of
the theology but i know there are a lot
of great catholics who do not agree with
this current pope
on issues that don't relate to
spirituality okay so i want to be clear
this is not an attack on catholics
however um there's no hope with pope
there is no hope with the pope
stupid little red shoes here he is
saying the pope
that we need to abandon individualism
and liberty
for the collective good we've had to
translate it this is an actual
uh he gave us at a vaccine conference
[Music]
well and i know that the whole thing
with the pope is he's only infallible on
issues of spirituality and speaking as
cathedral but you know what
um i i we're supposed to be reverential
to the pope but i'm not
[Music]
here communist pope
you've got to do listen we're talking
about cowards
time for you to speak out against this
pope yeah okay yeah not good okay i will
i'm catholic there you go
do it in the lose you're a lapse
catholic dude well i'm a recovering
catholic the principle was the same
i learned it all and then i was like i
don't like the pedophilia
oh i'm sorry what did i just make that
up yeah
have you not seen spotlight gerald you
didn't pull that out of the reverse
triangular hat
yeah i did like spotlight especially the
end credits where it said it all
happened and you're like
where every city yeah why is this longer
than the movie
this pope come on man look stay in your
lane and also that you've got at a
certain catholics you've got to start
speaking out there needs to be
more cat there need to be more catholics
in this country if you believe
right there it's the perfect opportunity
you can just say no i disagree with the
pope
i agree i agree individualism and
liberty is more important you know what
jesus was kind of pro liberty and the
jail christian foundings of this country
were based on the idea of
life liberty pursuit of happiness so the
pope can take his commie [ __ ]
elsewhere
i want to see catholics being less
cowardly because they're afraid that
they might offend and i know that i have
so many people who come up and talk
about this they say
i don't know man i this pope i don't
know what the deal is something seems to
be going wrong
again uh this is something right now the
theme of today
is cowardice it is i think it is
the bit when we talk about the
perversion or the subversion of american
culture
i think it all it all comes from making
people subservient and it comes from
really taking advantage of people's
cowardice yeah and people like the pope
in a position that is unquestionable
like you can't question the pope
necessarily if you're a catholic and and
remain kind of a good catholic in good
standing right amongst you some
catholics yeah well no to a lot of
catholics they would just take offense
to it right
right and they would say oh well he was
talking about making sure that we're not
self
you know self kind of absorbed in
everything that we do and to maybe
provide for you i mean like living in a
city of gold and having a man whose only
job is not to make pope shoes not to
make red shoes
to make the pope's exclusively red shoes
just like that i'm not sure
who chose the red shoes and why that has
to stay a thing but don't be a
narcissist
says the pope yeah it's not the wizard
of oz except he just gives the cowardly
lion a vaccine
yeah do you think he ever tried to
change the wretch can we try like
white shoes he has a different shoe he
doesn't always wear the red shoes but
you know what paul my special
shut up hey you know what pope if you
talked about the message of salvation
as often as you do communist philosophy
and critical race
hey maybe you'd be of value to the
christian world i don't know
well as a catholic part of part of it is
it is based on guilt a lot of it and
that's why you have this representative
that you can't say anything against and
that's what's kind of scary
yeah he's just another human being
that's what people have to realize right
he is another human being
and you are allowed to say something
yeah you're allowed to say that oh no i
don't think we should abandon individual
liberty
because i think this pope is a communist
okay
here's something else too i want to
preface this this is a story just just
came out
i think it was yesterday it came out the
day before this happened there's a fox
reporter
a latino la officer pulled over a crazy
racist woman
uh and uh he by the way it's important
to note that this department or this
precinct didn't have body cam
uh body cameras he paid for it himself
for his own investment
uh yeah he said to protect his job yeah
yeah
and i've spoken with some some police
officer friends and this was shocking to
a lot of people they said oh yeah
this happens all the time my wife to be
clear my wife heard this from the other
room this is going to be enraging
uh and she said well there you go they
see it's not just it's not a black thing
that's the
spoiled white woman there who's bought
into the lie and hates cops and i said
no this woman is black she goes oh see i
wanted to hit her when i thought she was
white
fair and balanced and she's pregnant
with twins that's
that's like throwing a marciano punch
she can really lay
into it yeah so here is a clip where
this officer is calling a
mexican-american
uh sorry this lady is calling a
mexican-american officer a murderer
and a racist and this is what they have
to deal with this is the environment
we've created
today because i was going under the
speed limit i was going at 38.
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40
and i was going 38 so why are you
harassing you are correct
i pulled you over because you're a
murderer
may i have your driver's license i it's
it's at my
apartment do you have your driver's
license i
it i mistakenly left it at home do you
have a poor you driver's license
may have it it's quite a rock on her
finger a happy man might get it for you
i already did he's on his way because
you're a murderer okay
i have a right to and record the police
when they're harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i would i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that do you
have a pictured man made
that's not just a feeling you're a
murderer oh my god can you
zoom in on that for me yeah thank you
and i'm perfectly
legal and i'm a teacher so then oh the
real
teacher
they're threatening to kill me and my
son can you okay
and your son
is your signature he's only citing you
for using your cell phone while you're
driving that's it there you go bam
sign inside the river for him being a
mexican racist
what is that name was that even what
it's under citation man
here you go mexican racist whoa you're
always going to be a mexican you'll
never be white you know that right
wow where's ms-13 when you need him
oh my god i want to see her head moving
in slo-mo in the foreground on top of a
turtle
i just i just would almost walk up and
yell gun
yeah you're just jogging bye
sorry [ __ ]
wow oh just by the way everything there
victim victim victim
we've gotten rid of right and wrong it's
what's the hierarchy of victimhood
oh you're trying to kill me i'm a woman
i'm a teacher i don't care
she's a teacher of i guess dealing crack
mercedes and like yeah
yeah yeah she got a beeper and people
will be more offended that i implied
dealing cracker
because i think she's a woman of color
no i'm saying because she's a horrible
person by the way
she's calling someone a mexican racist
yeah not even realizing the irony that
she's being completely racist
garcia whatever you'll never be white
okay i feel free i don't
we have with these understand officers
by the way she tried to file a formal
complaint she
filed other formal complaints and this
is something when people for example
we're gonna move into the shove and
trial when people say there were
complaints issued and you know what we
need to have all these records unsealed
every cop will tell you that they have
on a on an almost daily basis at least
several times a week someone claiming
they're going to have their badge
someone filing a complaint because they
didn't want to get a ticket i'm sorry
you can't just say well this officer has
18 complaints therefore
they need to be suspended it can't be
based on some number that complaint
if not for him purchasing his own body
cam
might be on his record that he
threatened to murder somebody and that
he was racist toward a woman of color
this is a horrible horrible environment
that we've created the united states
and most people agree by the way
including most black people over
what was it 68 the last time they
checked so we want at least as much
police presence
as we have or more but people are afraid
to speak out
stop being cowards what do you think
she's telling her son she said you're
threatening to
kill me and my son in the car i'm like
oh great
now her son's in the car with that mom
thinking we're going to have
cops kill us every time they pull us
over and cite us for
using our cell phone she lies to him a
lot though he's still waiting for
you know his dad to come back with
cigarettes oh what are you saying there
question i'm trying to tell you the
sketch
oh what oh that's right oh okay that's
right i forgot now to be oh no
thank you i tried no after all of this
is diatribe
we yeah boy do we have egg in our face
because to be fair in her defense uh
the captain question was this
so there you go there you go he's
context
he's king folks thank you for the black
carrot i was being incredibly
unprofessional i'm sorry
i thought he was saying that someone
here said something out of line i need
better hand signals
i i was trying to buy you time i'm glad
he was just no one here said anything
that could get us banned instead he was
telling us we need the
hitler don lemon sketch that
i feel good about our choices today i do
too so let's go on so
here uh let's move on to this and you
know we've all had these discussions and
i know we disagreed on on the shaving
trial
a lot of americans did but i think
here's something that we can
agree upon this was a trial that's
public right this was
this was not justice in the sense that
you had jurors who were intimidated
jurors who were terrified and
jurors who thought that they could use
uh their position
as a juror supposed to be impartial to
try and affect
social change as opposed to being
concerned with justice where does this
come from
brandon mitchell one of them said on an
april 27 podcast
titled get up mornings with erica
campbell
i already hate wow uh he said that
people should join juries
that's how it works yeah that's not how
it works you don't just join juries
you don't just go like i would like to
volunteer
right i would like to be dumb enough to
not be able to get out of
jury duty yeah especially that trial i'd
be like i'm so racist can i go
he's totally guilty viciously racist
i can't decide i'm glad it's this trail
because first i thought i might have to
uh
issue some kind of a rolling on a nation
i packed a lunch will i be needing no
okay oh that's a shame
you just put your clan head on and leave
where's the door it's everything is
paneled here and the eyeholes are small
i can't see
um so on the podcast he said that people
should join
juries to promote societal change oh
there you go
we're talking to brandon mitchell he was
juror number 52
in the derrick chauvin murder trial
brandon before we rap many people
don't like jury duty and probably
wouldn't only him
and ernest get in the mail so what
message
about saying yes to jury duty i mean
it's important if we want to see some
change we want to see some things going
differently we got to get out there and
get into these avenues and get in these
rooms
um to try to spark some change right
that's when jury dude is one of the
things jury duty voting
all those things and things you got to
do
well that's that'll just be used for a
mistrial
you would think so yeah am i wrong just
get in these rooms all right we need to
deliberate who is
it by the way he was photographed in
2020 because we all want to believe that
this is an impartial journey he's
looking at everybody's
guilty what do you think innocent guilty
like i said
he white i'm the captain now this jury
belongs to me
so 2020 he was wearing a shirt that said
get your knee off our neck so we know
this now
um at the march in washington where
george floyd's brother
spoke by the way if you're watching
right now hit the notification bell
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot really quickly and you'll
know it's a it's a show monday through
thursday at 10 a.m eastern
um no i don't know oh okay this is a
juror yeah yeah
that's really him yeah not the
notification bell but yes oh no i know
the notification a jury
a juror or as you should uh refer to him
one of your peers
yes uh juror number 44 too as we go
through this
said during jury selection that she'd
viewed the bystander footage of floyd
and schaben and it left her with a
negative view of shaban so right away
that's not someone who's going in
unbiased
number 92 wrote that uh her uh in her
juror questionnaire
floyd didn't deserve to die the police
uh shouldn't have used excessive force
that's a conclusion that's already been
drawn before she has seen the evidence
and this is where it brings us again to
the theme of the day cowardice so maybe
those people have opinions
and they're wrong and that's not how
jury duty should take place right this
is why they need to be sequestered
there's that movie the jury with john
uh grisham
yeah except he didn't go on the show
afterwards and say see we set it up
right great we got those gun
manufacturers but these people have
these opinions right and they're going
in they're trying to affect change
they've said this
person has said that's their mission and
then you have other people we'll never
really know what they think
all we really know is they were scared
is they were intimidated they were
scared and that did affect their
decision making so here's an example of
someone who
maybe we don't know where they lined up
but we know that they were terrified
lisa christensen said she was concerned
about protesters
coming to her house she was concerned
about being doxed she said that she had
to wade through dante white protesters
to get home because she lived in
brooklyn center
so this is we just had those jurors
saying
guilty guilty guilty before the trial
effectively and then this lady who maybe
went in with an open mind saying
did it affect my decision well you be
the judge
i had mixed feelings there was a
question on the questionnaire about that
and i put i didn't know um because the
reason at that time was
obviously i didn't know what the outcome
was going to be did garth
wayne i felt like either way the outcome
was you're gonna disappoint one group or
the other
so i didn't want to go through this
whole rioting
[Music]
and destruction again and you know a
little concerned about people outside my
house if
they weren't happy with the verdict she
knew the case was huge
the christensen had no idea she would be
so close during the trial
to another death caused by police near
her home
in brooklyn center so when i came home i
could hear the helicopters flying over
my
outside i house see the smoke from those
smoke grenades going on
i had a hard time getting to my house
because all the protesters were blocking
the intersections and stuff so i had to
go way around
just to get home so i was aware but it
did not affect me at all
yeah she just went through six minutes
about stuff that she'll have to be
unloading with her therapist for decades
to come but no i wouldn't
say that i went back to my uh job as the
junk muppet and labyrinth yes
oh no uh
all right so this is just one again
they're they're
we are struggling with cowardice right
now we are struggling with cowardice
people who are afraid to speak up we
expect the left to throw tantrums
we expect unfortunately this is a sad
state of affairs the riots and the
burning down and the lies from the media
we expect but the issue right now is
people who are not standing up to do the
right thing and we'll
we'll get into education in a little bit
and also um what's happening with the
police force but uh first off hey
go to kridershop.com you can buy this
fight like health yes by the way
we don't mean physically fight we mean
that you need to fight everything uh
sometimes physically like hermit crabs
looking for a larger shell if you need
if you're living in a coke can
and you prefer a larger shell sometimes
you have to fight
in spirit uh and uh we're gonna take
your chat
uh we have police uh smooth name the
police sketch artist a little bit and
the best thing you can do
comment just leave a comment below as to
how are you fighting every day this is
something everyone needs to check
themselves every day we've talked about
checking your heart for gratitude we've
talked about checking yourself for
um you know righteousness you check
yourself for cowardice it is a
poison and i tell you this i lived
through high school
as a coward i was bullied and i didn't
really fight back i was always afraid
and there was a turning point after i
you know sprouted up six inches and
about 50 pounds i was a lightning
angry late bloomer and i said okay
that's that's not going to happen
anymore
and i remember one time in my life no
i've talked about this not being a bully
but not helping a kid who i knew was
being bullied
and i i felt horrible i felt so bad i
said you know i'm never going to do that
again i'm never going to let that happen
again if something is in my power
at some point you guys have to flip a
switch and make this decision yourself
and when everyone in the united states
makes that switch that's the only way
we'll see actual change it's not change
comes from you in some abstract way
change comes from you once you grow a
backbone people in america need to grow
a backbone not saying be a douche
not saying go out and look to start
trouble i'm saying go out and if you're
strong enough
protect those who are vulnerable and
can't defend themselves you
need to start stepping up everybody okay
people who don't want to step up this is
something that's been going on by the
way this is at uh
vox an article but um this has been
talked about quite a bit
not only do we talk about defunding the
police but now woke activists are
talking about
how to police your own community oh how
you should handle these situations in
the absence of police
be a vigilante no no no no no no no no
no not that at all that would
make too much sense oh and it'd be cool
i have a spider-man costume oh
no they want they want no paul cursey
though that's where that's where things
will go
that's where things will go if you don't
have police it's already there almost i
think it's starting to happen can we
bring up overlay end from vox
uh they ran an article in april
encouraging people not to call the cops
what did they suggest instead they
suggest learn about local mental health
resources
great okay uh you first vox
if you're not calling the cops when
there's an emergency you should look
into mental health yes
yeah they say take a community approach
to stopping violence and we'll get into
some specifics which are just hilarious
they say seek resources to learn more
about racial justice
well that's great with a crackhead and a
beanie with a knife
yeah that'll stop him how have i wronged
you oh oh
now i'm just now i'm sprinkling out
water like uh
gremlins i apologize for my white blood
getting on you
yeah and here's something this is
something that's from vox right now
being pushed in the mainstream this is
not new i want to be really clear about
it a lot of people think that defunding
the police
is where it ends and they will say some
democrats so we don't really want to
defund the police we want to restructure
police no they want to defund police and
they've done it in many municipalities
but that's not all they want they not
only want to defund the police they want
you to live in a crime-ridden
poverty zone in all of your generations
from here after that's what they want
for you
because they believe that you should not
call the cops and they're actually
coaching you
instructing you on how to never call the
cops all predicated of course
on racism and cowards go along with it
here you go this is what to do instead
of calling the police
[Music]
our police presence often escalates
rather than reducing the risk of
violence in a situation someone pooped
on
because police have been trained to see
people of color gender non-conforming
folks
and muslims as criminals they often
treat victims
as perpetrators of violence so if the
victim hasn't
asked you to call the police do not
what if they gurgled do not call the
police
what it's telling people is don't call
the cops
you want your child to live don't even
call the cabinet oh my god okay so uh
some other suggestions they make create
a safety plan these are very abstract
right
create a safety plan do not call the
cops
the guy just got pushed on the third
rail what do you want me to do well
observe take mental inventory
think of your community put on your poop
emoji hat and kiss your ass goodbye
write down this is something they say
they say write down what makes you happy
ah okay let people shoplift these are
all they're stabbed
not being stuck hold on let me take out
my notepad
thank god i'm not the one being killed
right now list your gratitudes well up
until this moment i didn't realize just
how nice it was to not be filled with
cold steel signed mister they're taking
my baby
don't it always seem to go that you
don't know what you got till you're
stabbed
they sell they say smelling and tasting
things these are in the clips and
massaging yourself these are how they
talk about how to deal
with criminal activity in your here's
another montage
all the sources are available at
louderwithcrowder.com the first step is
to write down affirming thoughts and
beliefs
and this can feel kind of like woo-woo
and silly to write these items
but when you do this before a crisis
happens it really helps redirect
your mind when you are starting to feel
that crisis
so really think about why you want to be
safe
what parts of your life make you feel
the most proud or excited or happy
and we need to take action in and by
ourselves you know in doing things to
change that internalization those
mindsets but also
um by working with others and creating
that kind of community
that has less police and needs less
police
do you need to do anything about the
person shoplifting from target
no it's not harming anybody it's not
your business what if you own a target
you start listing things that you can
observe with your senses right
these are things that you can see or
hear or smell or taste or touch i think
it can be really helpful to massage
yourself when you're in a crisis
situation
it releases that oxytocin that really
helps you kind of
feel good in your head and it also kind
of
makes you be mindful of muscle tension
so massaging your neck
or your shoulders also kind of giving
yourself some compression on your chest
kind of simulating a hug
and do a little butterfly hugs and
butterfly tops
oxytocin good use apparently now
neurotransmitters and hormones are a
thing
good uh so yeah massage yourself which
obviously brings us because you know
cops was canceled brings us to this
week's uh installment of
the rebooted uh no cops
tonight on no cops
give me the money oh give me the money
are you kidding me
stay tuned for more no cops
should be noted they're both dead yes
yeah well one bullet though
it was immediate well he he died in
comfort his shoulders were not intense
yeah
the gunman then turned it on himself
right yeah yeah he just didn't like them
but
only he he ran out like at the end of
the mist
waste this time nobody hears a [ __ ]
about stephen king's tweets
so just this last week by the way mayor
bill de blasio
in case you don't know america's mayor
oh he announced that the nypd will no
longer be responding to mental health
crisis calls instead they're calling
social workers
wonderful hey and this is also the issue
first off
um you sorry
first off you're if you're not a social
worker social workers are about as
useless as the person with the poop
emoji hat
uh but the issue here is
you don't know what kind of drug someone
is on you don't
know what kind of a weapon they have and
social workers
aren't equipped to deal with it let's
say a situation like micaiah bryant you
didn't know that she was about to stabby
stab
until that last fraction of a second
yeah and uh hickok 45
did the neighborhood a favor oh wait
hold on a second what are you uh are you
saying that mckay bryant deserved to be
shot yes yes i am absolutely yeah yeah
no regrets
100 in that moment she deserved to be
shot there is no doubt about it and by
the way just
i think like days before they released
this
policy saying hey we're no longer going
to do this officers responded to a
wellness check very
you know benign right somebody just
going to check on them yeah well it
ended up in a standoff and two officers
were killed
what do you think is going to happen if
you send social workers into that
environment
right less social workers yeah yeah
we're probably going to end up
with social workers i'm down for this
almost oh wait a second wait a second is
donald trump playing 11d
no don't send the social workers
don't do that especially not in
what's
i hope the italian mob comes roaring
back
no seriously you need them now you need
them now they knew how to police
everything
they had their businesses it's i'm
telling you i live there it needs the
mob back
you're going to see trash picked up
nightclubs are going to have
bums in front of them it's going to be
great also
bring back the mob yeah that's where i
stand
yeah you racist italians we are a racist
italian yeah yeah what the [ __ ] you
gonna do
all right now i'm taking your hubcaps oh
and whatever you got in your wallet
okay phrases italian it's a little
redundant ain't it baby
you know listen i'm sicilian i'm just
saying there's a black man hiding in my
wood pile somewhere down the line you
and i could be brother and sister only
i'm not an
[ __ ] yeah i call your supervisor
you can't go with it oh yeah you want to
call my supervisor yeah
very boombox hey vinnie uh he says go
[ __ ] yourself
you want to call his supervisor it'll be
even funny exactly
i can do this all night come on
basically
once you go high up enough we're no
longer dealing with the patsies for the
higher ups it's just the four families
you ever seen an olive garden commercial
they're horrible
we're nothing like that we just shoot
you
all right like olive garden deserves
yeah like olive garden desserts hey
where's a pipe bomb when you need one
yeah is that a lasagna stick did you
just say this to me
with a straight face what do you mean
your test kitchen in tuscany
yeah i'm gonna slap this [ __ ] i just
flew in from florence the [ __ ] took me
to the olive garden thanks
i'm having a whacked
oh yeah you know how they have that on
the kids menu whack the server it looks
a little it looks fun i get it no i get
it now
you're still gonna die okay so let's go
in here uh to uh uh critical race there
we've done a full segment on this and by
the way all the sources are available at
loudest cutter.com you can type in if
youtube search is working
um crowd or critical race through we've
done more of a deep dive as a term
that kids use on that um but this is
important just in the sense of of
not only critical race three there are
things that exist in the periphery right
things that exist in the orbit that are
still being implemented in schools
um last week during his joint address to
congress
former vice president joe biden uh he
talked about the american family's
infrastructure plan
yeah and so we assumed that that had to
do with bridges and roads no no no
he talked about funding of course and
emphasizing more funding to education so
we'll set this up and then explain to
you what that means and what is
happening
the great universities this country have
conducted studies of the
last 10 years and shows that adding two
years of universal high quality
preschool
for every three-year-old and
four-year-old no matter what background
they come from
puts them in the position to be able to
compete
all the way through 12 years unless
they're a girl in sports and increases
exponentially their
prospect of graduating and going on
beyond graduation obey
research chose when a young child goes
to school not daycare
they're far more likely to graduate from
high school
and go to college or something after
high school
prison when you add two years of free
community college on top of that
you begin to change the dynamic
and i've made this and people get mad at
me i don't think that we need to be
adding time to education i think we need
to be shaving off time and making it
more efficient
i i really do i don't think that having
kids in school starting at three
and paying all the way through 19 or
however
how old do you graduate eighteen and
eighteen yes okay i graduated a year
early and we graduated like at 17
i was 16. so uh i was almost 20. you
were almost 21 graduated high school
yeah did you actually function i was 19.
i did i did it
five years oh wow well yep i liked the
well my parents put me in daycare
slippery slope into drugs he makes a
good point
yeah um oh my gosh you want 16 years of
your life to be spent
in education on the front and this is
good and if
if we were talking about education like
adding up you know
doing math your multiplication tables
long division
learning about history sciences but
that's not what's happening
and this is where the agendas are being
implemented and this is a problem with
some people say well you know we're just
printing more money
it's not just the x amount of hundreds
of billions or trillions of dollars at
this point six trillion
dollars from his inauguration up to the
proposals it's about what hides
in these bills yeah and sometimes it's
too late where you i had no idea when we
were teaching kids that
what yeah it was in there he didn't read
it because it was 19
000 pages the only exception being the
green new deal which is like four and a
half
if you double space and use a size 19
font so
uh what biden's not telling is the
education department's proposed
priorities for schools and this is um
from the new york times uh 1619 project
and work from ibramax so here we go this
is let's let's talk about the 1619
project really quickly this is something
i want to implement and this is
something you've talked about in the
past
yeah so i mean what you have to
understand about the 1619 project is
that it's basically pulling all of these
ideas together all these different
people and putting it into
one kind of theme that says the united
states
is a racist country to its core that it
was founded on racism that slaves
actually came over and founded this
country
essentially before we got here and that
that has
kind of done everything to shape the
country that we live in today
and so that's not incorrect the native
americans did have slaves
they did they did have slaves they're
like hey we already did this
yes you guys are unoriginal right but
their whole basis is to say look
everything that we do now and teaching
people about history in this country is
wrong right we're teaching civics
incorrectly we're saying that these are
people to revere
the founding fathers of this country and
the people who started this country and
that's wrong they were actually racist
to the core and the only way that we can
make this society better is if we teach
you
the actual racist systemic issues of
this country from the beginning
right and that's also where 6019 comes
from it's 1619 right that's when
slaves first landed in virginia so the
idea is that's really when america was
created they want this to be a part of
the curriculum this is the department of
education
again the sources are available on our
website uh they want slavery to be
recognized not only as america's
original sin
but its origin and this is important
this is important too because
i did a video a long time ago in 2009 i
believe where i went to berkeley and
there was a late this was the subject
this was before
hidden cameras i remember i just put i
put a a photo camera
in a trucker hat yeah and just put and
cut a hole in it
it didn't look and i just had to pick
going into the classes that were in the
biggest lecture halls
and i asked this teacher you can type in
steven crowder berkeley if the search
engine works on youtube
get smart yeah exactly and she was
talking about slaves she said you know
these slaves were taken from the old
world
and they were taken into the new world
and then they were they were uh forced
to be slaves and i said yeah yeah
question
professor who is teaching this exact
topic your area of expertise
how many of these slaves were slaves in
the old world
and were sold into slavery versus you
know kidnapped with giant nets and
turned into slaves
that's a very good question i don't know
the answer to that it could be 96
at the lowest it's 85 and you can take
that from cornell west
wow yeah she didn't know that and then
she talked about how uh
the reason that these people were slaves
and that they came over and they were
really effective in tilling some of
these fields
she asked students to go through reasons
as to why this might be the case and i
said yeah could it be because they had
experience being slaves in the old world
not excusing it by the way but it would
seem to be relevant as job experience is
the first thing you list on your resume
she said
no i don't think and she went on some
diatribe as to why it was about systemic
racism
this is a lie that they teach your kids
and i sat there
and i had a kid next to me afterwards
say like yeah you know i wanted to ask
that same thing
cowardice that's the issue cowardice is
the issue right now
no one out there who actually you can
say that america
obviously slavery is a black dot in
history of course everyone here would
agree with that
we are not uniquely responsible for
creating slavery we are uniquely
responsible for ending it and fighting
one of the bloodiest wars
in history certainly a domestic war to
end
slavery okay that is important to note
and anyone who teaches hey you know what
this is
something we're responsible for we
created slavery is lying
and anyone who is silent is a coward so
i want you to comment just comment how
can you stand up
in your class when have you remained
silent people used to ask me hey should
i keep my head down i said keep your
head down get your grade finish school
not anymore also smash that like button
everyone watching live right now
to all of you i have no idea i know it's
probably quite a few just hit
that like button because this helps us
on youtube because we do not show up in
search or suggest
as many of you know right now if you
type in stephen crowder berkeley um it
teaches 1619 that american
exceptionalism grew out of anti-black
racism
right man
one of the authors matthew desmond wrote
in order to understand the brutality of
american capitalism you have to start
on the plantation um it also sources
uh candy's novel how to be anti-racist
so it's critical race theory yeah
it pretty much and basically they're
tying education funding to this so
for you to get and now it's it's not a
huge amount of money but it is millions
of dollars
for schools to get millions of dollars
they have to teach it this way
yeah well overall it ends up being
billions of dollars when you add
everything up
yeah well the whole program yeah we're
just talking about 1619 keep in mind
they also how much money
gone right we're talking about the 1776
initiative from donald trump which is to
teach kids that hey
america's a pretty good country gone
that's gone yeah yeah
and it doesn't whitewash anything that's
overlay if you want to bring that up
yeah it doesn't whitewash anything the
1776 project just says hey we are
something
unique here this is a good thing we have
things that we've done horribly wrong
just like every other country in
existence the only thing is we're going
to go ahead and say hey
we did that wrong let's learn from it
right let's not just cover up the
history and say everybody was racist
and they also this is giving people one
more excuse everything that's wrong with
you and your society right now is
because this country is founded on
racism
yeah right it's not the fact that you
know they're talking about schools oh if
we just add two more years
how about this joe how about you talk
about the number one determinant if
somebody's going to graduate from high
school or not is if they have a mom and
a dad in the house yeah or a mom and a
dad that care or even a mom
or a dad that spends time with them and
make sure they they do their homework
even more how about you talk about the
affirmative action and the quota
policies that you supported that locked
out asian students from brown and from
ivy league universities because they
were scoring too high and the average
asian american media and household
income is higher than that
of white americans or black americans
despite the fact that they were also
slaves who built the railroads oh and by
the way
their grandparents were put in
internment camps
are bad sorry well as far as sex slavery
goes they're still
they're still yeah people don't realize
this for some reason well slavery still
exists
yeah in so many ways in the world well
it exists as basic slavery in the middle
east
and then here you have sex but you can't
talk about that because then you need to
talk about
securing the borders because a huge
portion of sex labor in the united
states happens with
what people being trafficked across the
border can't talk about that
so we don't really care about the
victims again cowardice people
don't speak out just look into sex
slavery just a little bit i mean
obviously put your safe search i'll do
some research put your safe search on
um and again back to america's mayor de
blasio announced
in january that he was this is another
thing because it's racist
i'm about to say something that you're
going to go well how does this make
sense well it doesn't if you assume
systemic racism
eliminating entry exams for new york
city schools
the gift and talented test is the
definition of a high stakes test
a single test that determines so much
this approach to testing is not
something i believe in it's not
something
the chancellor believes in it's
something that's caused a lot of
frustration for so many
families at this point in the year a lot
of families had already prepared they
were counting on the opportunity we
respect that so we'll go forward
but we will not be providing that test
in the future
we need a much better approach to
serving kids
who have a lot of capacity that's great
some kids
have a lot of teeth i think that signer
has his mega death t-shirt
under the button down but that's a lot
of kids
speaking of kids here's a picture of my
daughters
on the subway small amount of gifted and
talented programs that exist
okay good by the way really quickly on
cnn they just said hey uh pfizer
applying for full fda approval
you know that there are tens of millio
tens of millions of americans who
already got the shots
what wait huh
what do you mean approval pardon me it's
well actually it's worse than that
steven it's emergency approval for
vaccines for kids two to eleven
oh okay well good because that's an
emergency group right things are
turning up five so it's like the movie
casino they just kept moving it to the
bottom of the pile right yes exactly
pretty much now so they go back to de
blasio he wants to do away with standard
entry exams this comes despite the fact
that over
140 new york city schools uh had at
least
one grade where more than 90 percent
of students failed to state exams in
2019 this is before covet mind you
is this racist i don't understand how
tests are racist yeah no that we're
going to get into why
tests are racist and i'm not even trying
to be funny doesn't this just decide if
you have
like you know mental handicap i well i
don't i tried to listen to what de
blasio was just saying and i didn't
understand it like
i didn't either i think he is mentally
indicative
i think he's just doing away i think
that this guy i think this is the
greatest i guess political coup in
history
he failed all of his entry exams as a
kid and he said
i'll show them light and wait yeah for
about 40 or 50 years
and then boom did away with the ones
that screwed him standardized testing
long con fake name too like he's not
even italian it sounds fake
sounds fake i think de blasio is not his
name i'm not i'm just saying well let's
have uh let's see legendary over there
research allegedly
and this is something else before we go
back to tests just again going back to
cowardice just a few weeks ago grace
church
uh there was a school teacher there
named paul rossi i wanna make sure i get
this name correctly
uh correct sorry he was uh relieved from
teaching that means fired by the way
yeah
for writing a new york post op-ed and it
was titled we're damaging kids with
critical race theory so he was fired
from his teaching position okay
unbelievable just by saying we're
damaging kids critical race theory again
go do some research on critical race
three white people bad patriarchy bad
basically original sin that white people
should be ashamed of something that is
completely outside of their control and
this person wrote by the way a very
measured
column in the new york post saying i
think we're damaging our kids
this is shared by the way with about
half the country
um but here's the here's the kicker the
head of grace church
george davidson was then caught on audio
after after this guy was fired
during a conversation with rossi
agreeing
with the fact that the school demonizes
white kids through critical race theory
here it is record it
the fact is that i'm agreeing with you
that there has been a demonization that
we need
to get our hands around in the way in
which people are doing this
understanding okay so you agree that
we're demonizing kids we're demonizing
um kid we're demonizing white people
for being born and are some of our
students white people
what are some of our students white
people yes
okay so we're demonizing white we're
demonizing white kids
why don't you just say it right we are
using language that makes them feel
less than um for nothing that they are
personally responsible for by the way
the fact that that guy didn't realize he
was being recorded
he should fire himself do we have any
white students
what why are you asking such direct
poignant questions strange
well also answering it in a roundabout
way is not going we're making them feel
less then
yeah did i get away with that yeah did i
get away with that no
hello yeah is there someone listening
we're making them feel less than
so okay let's just flip it what if you
were to say that insert race here
is less than hmm
that's almost the definition of racism
not recognizing racial differences mind
you
there's nothing racist about recognizing
the differences between people of
different races you don't have to be
colorblind that was a lie too
but thinking that someone is less than
exclusively because of their race which
is what
critical theory teaches you'll say well
no they're not saying that white people
are less than
we're just saying they have more to
atone for simply through being born
white
i would say that's being born with extra
baggage
just because of your race again i would
say by the definition of racism
it's racist and not even just more to
atone for like there's some
original sin that we're born with as
being white is that we are less than
because we are inherently racist we're
incapable of seeing people
outside of the lens of race yeah that's
the comment us and mexicans
racist mexican cop you're trying to
murder me
he pretended to be italian no he he
changed his name because
his mom's name was de blasio her maiden
name was de blasio still a liar he's
still a liar
he's why he was absolutely a liar a liar
we already knew he was a liar but you
know what he was
a liar he wants the the governor job
right now uh of new york
yeah he said he really hates old
following right now he's like oh yes
i've got you cuomo yeah he works out
more old handsy
i uh with this though i've talked to a
lot of teachers who are
who teach young students the real heroes
the real heroes i've spoken to not just
the ones that work at
you know fast food places during the
pandemic other heroes
but i've talked frontline workers yes
frontline workers that's correct
god's gift yes they're going into the
automated mcdonald's drive-through and
hearing the
the sounds of d-day just now would you
like fries
that's not what's happening no i'm white
i like hero spit
it's there but i've talked to a lot of
teachers preschool teachers
and they say they are completely and
very concerned with what they have to
teach students because they do think
that it demonizes the white kids
yeah now that being said with this guy
getting fired and we're talking about
cowardice
is what can they really do because now
you've put something on the line like
their job the way they make a living
that's know what we're at the point
where people are just gonna have to be
willing to do it it's gotta become world
war z where it's just a mountain of
bodies on a wall
where you can't even see the difference
between the wall and it's just gotta be
so much people are gonna have to say
look hey
we're not we're gonna run out of people
who want to be teachers we can't only
take it from the afro-lesbian underwater
basket weaving department
it's a niche market guys
but we are being crippled financially as
a society
and that's the eradication of the middle
class and it makes it hard for people
well i think what people also need to do
is when you start homeschooling yeah
you're pulling out your kids from people
like oh
oh the pandemic made me realize i want
to send my kids back to school well then
you must really hate your kids
and by the way it's the only way right
now and this is why in other countries
homeschooling is very limited when i was
in canada i knew one kid who was
homeschooled his name was simon we
thought he was [ __ ]
they used to be pretty anti-social
weirdos yeah they used to
but now the truth is kids at school are
anti-social weirdos
there's so many ways to socialize your
kid if you homeschool them you can get
them
in intramural activities it doesn't have
there are systems that
exist there are programs in place where
you can play for a team but if you're a
walk-on with your locals
there are tons of options now and look
if you're going to send your kid to
public school sometimes that's the only
option you have i get it try to find
another option but if you can't get
involved with your school board
people around the country right now are
starting to go to their school boards
and say
enough's enough and if you guys don't
change like an entire school board
was basically ousted that's right yeah
recently and the crowd just was
in there saying look these are our kids
these are our
children you don't get to decide they
don't believe that though they don't
believe that they're your kids they
don't believe that you have the right to
teach your kids about sex
they don't believe that you have the
right to teach your kids about morality
they don't believe that you have the
right to teach your kids about the
the united states history they don't
believe that you have the right to teach
your kids about god they don't believe
that you have
they believe that they should own your
kids from you just heard it from the
former vice president's house
14 years now what 14 how many 16 years
16 years
16 years he can't even count that high
unless he's wearing sandals you're right
they don't believe that we need to as
uh desantis says disabuse them of that
notion well homeschool sex ed would be
weird
especially if you go to prom and you get
to go all the way yeah
homeschool prom let's make a flipper
baby
all right terrible
who's here keep on shining you're all
right though
um let's go to san francisco which by
the way is just as creepy as flipper
kids
it's just as creepy as flipper kids san
francisco in 2014 they stopped tracking
math courses
from the sixth through tenth grade
here's here are some slides from the
school district's presentation
right they read math is a web not a
ladder a web of lies
secondary math course sequence options a
social justice agenda
all students are mathematically
brilliant i hear the collective groans
of people whose forefathers were put in
internment camps
redefine what it means to do math okay
these are the same people saying trust
the scientific method
the beauty of math it and also what i
don't like about it
is it's rigid you cannot redefine it now
they do believe you can redefine it you
have certain curriculums
if you look at common core two plus two
does not equal four i know also
terence howard vehemently opposes
traditional math because he's a genius
he does have an oscar have you heard him
talk about it i have discovered new
mathematical sequences
no this is the way terence howard talks
we were taught the two plus two is three
but it's not really what if two plus two
is actually five
it's hard out here for a pimp i'm kind
of [ __ ]
in california not just san francisco
september of last year california
teachers
and education organizations meaning in a
lot of cases unions
released a toolkit what do you think it
was called was it called hey how to
improve
mathematical outcomes how to improve
standardized performance for students
no it's called a pathway to equitable
math instruction equitable again
this is something that people say a lot
like oh we shouldn't be concerned with
equity we should be concerned
shouldn't be concerned with equality we
should be concerned with equity the two
are diametrically opposed
you can either have equality meaning
everyone has an opportunity
or you can have equity meaning forced
outcomes which necessitates
the precluding of opportunities for
certain individuals how are you going to
determine that
race sex gender sorry because there's 57
right yeah equity is by the very
definition as they are teaching it
anti-equality people need to unders it
sounds really cool
and it's really nice for people who have
master's degrees in german poetry with a
minor in philosophy
they want to tell you that yeah it's not
about equality it's about equity well
how do you ensure equity how do you
ensure equal outcomes without infringing
not only on liberties
but equal opportunities it cannot be
done no you cannot have
an exact fixed number of black students
and asian students and white students
and reverse what you believe is systemic
racism in equal
in equity outcomes i'm getting confused
myself with ellen page yesterday
you cannot enforce equity outcomes and
have those numbers be consistent
a system designed to exclude specific
groups
from opportunities that are available to
others yeah and it's ali
yeah it's elliot what did i say you said
ellen again well you know what
i'm just a hateful prick well look and
what you just described is communism
it's the lowest common denominator you
can't
if if they were saying we're gonna raise
everybody up to the highest level
i think it would still fail but at least
that would be something that would be
better than what they're saying because
they're saying look
everybody has to come down to this level
so that everybody has an equal outcome
but top performers this is why china is
laughing at us because in china
they beat their kids in order to scare
them into performing
here we beat them down for
over-performing yes
wow that's well said oh i thought no
it's terrifying no i agree with you bob
well no just with math i mean
people have different talents i don't
know why anybody would have to explain
this i suck asians are better at math
yes they are but i heard in general well
yeah they are yes
i'm gonna stand by that a big part of
that too by the way is also because of
the the
their languages if you look like chinese
well yeah no it's yeah the structure of
their language
and it also lends itself to specificity
which is also why they're you know rice
is a very hard crop to cultivate as
opposed to corn in the united states
which is more robust
so if you actually look at the sort of
servants in in the asian world who are
working in rice fields
very different far more persnickety crop
anyway the point is
racial stereotype asians tend to be
better at math because statistics and
you know what
there are worse racial stereotypes that
could exist it's not even a
count your rocky stars indeed oh no i
was just saying i was terrible at math i
mean
yeah the only thing i learned is there
was 16 was it 16 ounces in a pound
28 grams in an ounce there you go
that's honestly the only thing i
remember from my once they helped to
show
all 10 fingers yes and once they added
letters
i was like i'm going to go get high
sense i have no idea what x equals and i
don't know so pathway to equitable math
instruction in california again we're
talking about this is what your taxpayer
dollars are going to
the toolkit is described as bring up
overlay k resources and guidance to
support black
latinx and multilingual students just to
thrive in grades six
through eight first off just right away
and i hate you should always check out
the sources
but anytime someone unironically writes
latinx [ __ ]
right off it feels lazy
the person who would use latinx is that
you're a racist mexican
you're a racist latinx right okay
so uh here we have slide one is uh
dismantling racism
in mathematics instruction its first
chapter includes an entire section on
dismantling white supremacy
in math classrooms some of the listed
ways
i look i'm i know it's like why are you
because i don't you know i don't have
like dr carlson or
shawn hey i don't have a prompter and i
want to make sure that i get this right
again you have all the sources available
to you i encourage you to read up on all
of this
because it is a pride swallowing speech
that i will never
fully tell you about this is
these are some of the listed ways math
perpetuates white
this is on equitablemath.org page seven
so you can follow along just following
follow the bouncing [ __ ] the focus on
getting the right answer that's a bad
thing
students are tracked we're back to
native americans here
you went north students are required to
show their work
grading practices are focused on lack of
knowledge i just look
i don't uh at a certain at a certain
point
i don't even have space for this do you
know why it's just focus
attendance and not cheating is a problem
yes do you know why students are asked
to show the work it's not only not
cheating the dave is right i just look
on the other paper and be like oh that's
12 fantastic yeah
yeah exactly it's to make sure that you
can help correct the flaw in the process
if you come to the incorrect answer it's
like do you know what they're not going
to be able to teach
math yeah all that schooling stuff take
it out yeah take it all out it's all
racist get it out how did i get this
wrong well hell i don't know i didn't
require you to show your work so just
keep trying
one time i failed a math exam in the
eighth grade because every single they
give you like sort of an empty box
to show your work that's how it works in
canada i drew a penis
every single box every single box well
did you at least add like different but
you know what my punishment was
was they made me retake the test did you
do in canada
i passed but barely nice
because i spent all the time on the ball
hairs you should you should at least
draw one piece yeah you put it in the
scantron it's all it's just
a plus
yeah depending on so look let's connect
these dots here again
we're talking about cowardice pope
coward people who are afraid to speak
out against the pope
cowards at this point catholic
protestant muslim i don't care many
voices need to speak out against
cowardice
we're talking about people now saying
not only do we need to defund the police
but you shouldn't call the police people
who don't speak up and say hey
that's actually going to victimize
people in these uh urban communities
you know who's not going to be
victimized by the black lives matter
movement and poop emoji hat
z people white people in rural
communities they need the police less
than anybody
they're the ones who go to their
neighbors and ask for a cup of sugar and
help them with their tractor right these
are the
people in urban areas particularly areas
with a lot of poverty
who need access to the police because
they don't know how to handle someone on
pcp with a machete
you're going to hurt yourself you're
going to put
your communities into an irreparable
situation
that you can't return and what happens
is a lot of people are afraid to speak
out they're afraid that we see this even
and you've talked about this with your
family members in the black community
you're not black just like joe biden
said just like a lawyer
tim scott was uncle tim right so people
are afraid well i saw what they did to
tim scott i don't want to speak up
now you see this with uh with the racial
equity when we're talking about schools
we're talking about billions and
billions of dollars
and people are afraid to go forward
people are afraid to go to the pta
meetings and say
hey you know what we just had an entire
trial
about whether oxygen deprivation can
actually lend itself to brain damage or
potentially killing someone
and i think it's a bad idea to put four
to six year olds
in a mask or double mask for for eight
hours a day
they're afraid to speak out you don't
have a choice at this point
the most pervasive problem in our
society right now
and the republican party is just a
reflection of that
not speaking out is cowardice so comment
you know i want to hear from how are you
guys going to
where have you recognized some cowardice
how are you going to correct it
and uh you know what else we're about to
do we're about to go to mug club so
people will talk about your chat
with credit.com and we have a smooth
manny the police sketch oh no that's
right yeah
which of course we could never do on
youtube no uh we're gonna see you
tomorrow
youtube we got 45 minutes that you
don't want none of this piss off